Chicago mayor Brandon Johnson spewing
some breathtaking BS over who's to blame
for the failed state of his City the
left-wing leader going on an excus a
paloa blaming everything from right-wing
extremists to his predecessor Tik Tock
Superstar Lori Lightfoot I miss her mind
you the last time a republican was in
charge of that place Herbert hoo was
running the country he was the 31st
president Dana oh yeah but before we
dive into what Brandon said here's a
quick refresher on the future site of
the
DNC shocking video shows a woman getting
robbed by a rifle wielding gang on a
busy Chicago Street before the perss
victimize three other people and Chicago
so overrun with migrants they're
stuffing illegal immigrants into police
stations churches airports and is soon
to be built Tent City residents who live
near the new camp are
protesting when you think about all the
things that we all ow to slide this is
another thing that you know we just
can't allow this to happen there's no
transparency from the mayor not even
from Alderman uh the Ramirez you know
it's very inhumane to do this this mayor
is acting like a dictator he needs to go
he must go typical right- wiers but
let's go back to Brandon Chicago's woke
mayor wants to blame everyone but
himself what we've seen is a very
raggedy form um instituted by right Wing
extremis extremism um everyone knows
that the right-wing extremism in this
country has targeted democratically ran
cities and quite frankly uh they've been
very intentional about going after
democratically ran cities that are led
by people of color it's the same
Republican right-wing extremism that
stormed the capital it's the same
right-wing extremism that refuses to
accept the results of the Civil War
they're still mad that a black man is
free in this country this is nothing new
but aren't you glad that the soul of
Chicago won't be broken and those are
the words of uh I think Beyonce you
won't break our soul oh
Jesse he's like taking a page out of
Jesse smollet's book it's like there's
this huge hidden extreme Maga you know
Crim criminal gang going around
carjacking and stuff I don't see any red
hats at the crime scenes oh well you
can't blame Biden for opening the Border
because the FBI will then raid your
house that's what they did here to our
mayor
I I don't understand why he's saying
that whites or conservatives are mad at
him blacks are mad at the black mayor
because he's turned the south side of
Chicago into Latin America no one can
even move in that neck of the woods
because they're just flooded with
migrants and you have to understand the
black community in Chicago is feeling
that they're being replaced and they've
said this they've said
that they're Americans and you're
importing a population there and they're
crowding them out of schools they're
crowding them out of soccer fields out
of basketball courts out of jobs and if
you look at the explosion in the
Hispanic population in this country it's
just astronomical they've doubled over
the last couple decades used to be 5% of
the population Hispanics now are 20% of
the population the Hispanic population's
doubling the black population in 2060
supposed to be flat they are just they
are having a lot of children they are
coming to this country they're they're
going to replace the political power of
the black community within the
Democratic party and the black community
in the Democratic party has been so
loyal to the Democratic party that they
can't understand why they would do that
and and that's what people are saying in
Chicago now this mayor is not trying to
fix anything he's just pointing
fingers he's not progressing these
people are saying oh were establishing
so much progress there's been no
progress in Chicago he's going to fail
just like all these other Progressive
Mayors are failing and then he's just
going to wind up at Harvard because
that's what they do Dana you look at a
lot of the problems that Chicago is
facing the migrant crisis crime gangs 10
cities these are not caused by
Republican policies it's kind of like
their political anger is being directed
at the people pointing out the problems
and not the problems themselves it's
like getting mad at your doctor for
diagnosing your illness because he's a
republican right well and also as
pointed out that wasn't exactly the
right-wing crowd that was holding the
press conference there hasn't been a
Republican mayor in Chicago I believe
since
1927 so I'm not sure how many people are
going to buy this uh since nove let's
see this year I'm sorry in the last six
months
15,192 cars have been stolen um we could
go through all the different burglaries
carjackings robberies but just imagine
if your city is so bad that a migrant
arrives takes a look around and says wow
you know what I think I'll try my luck
in Venezuela like where I might have a
better shot I felt like when he was
doing his press conference talking about
extremist Republicans he was almost like
trying out to be White House Press
Secretary because if he he knew it
wasn't going to land I don't know who he
thought he was trying to convince like
Shoring up his own base but it sounded
so forced and so Juvenile and it really
sounded like someone who's completely
out of his depth and I feel bad for
Chicago and I feel bad for all of the
mayor because the White House won't help
them yeah I I I I I felt sorry for him
that and I never feel sorry for people
empathy yeah I don't it was weird I
thought maybe I had the flu but it was
empathy feels weird right so judge the
great thing about Republicans is that
you can make fun of them all you want
but we still will help you right if he
could he could blame he could yell at us
but why doesn't he just say Okay help us
what should we do cuz Republicans will
help we're used to getting yelled at
here's the he knows what to do he knows
that there were 30 people who were shot
this past weekend after Thanksgiving he
is the person who appointed the
superintendent of police he is the one
who can say to the Police Superintendent
sit down let's talk about policy here I
don't really like your policy where the
police are not going to be punished for
not chasing a criminal I mean that is a
policy in Chicago so as people are
losing their their wallets and what we
saw in the first video when we started
this segment as people are being robbed
openly the police are not even choos
chasing them they're literally calling
in a Rob two on the corner of Michigan
and Center Street I mean that is his
fault it's his fault it's a sanctuary
City it's his fault the police are not
making arrest why not talk to your
Democrat Progressive da George Soros
funded da Kim Fox who messed up the JY
smallet case and say to her hey Kim stop
letting him out of jail you know we've
got real problems and then then for him
to turn around and say that there are
white people in this country who are
upset that blacks are free that was
outrageous to me first of all it took
white people to elect a black president
it took white people to make sure that
we've got laws on the books that don't
allow for discrimination I mean cut the
crap stop trying to be so divisive they
just want to create hate and hate they
claim this victimhood and then this
outrage when in the in the end even the
illegals are saying it's so bad here you
don't listen to minorities I'd rather go
back home Jessica I feel like uh there
okay there are two there are two issues
here and that he's deciding to go
towards one than the other the they're
the real issues the real problems and
then he goes but we're being targeted
we're being targeted and I assume he
means something like Fox News the media
who are constantly pointing out the the
degradation of liberal cities so what
it's like that's not your job your job
is not to uh address how the media media
portrays the city your job is to focus
on the problems that are being exposed
am I right nod or blink yes if I'm still
alive trapped in here um I want to
address that I first want to say that I
don't know who Jesse is talking to in
Chicago but I Haven on my show yeah I
don't think that black people are
sitting around talking about the great
replacement Theory and how they can't
get on a basketball court or wait a
second they had to have students leave
field because there wasn't enough room
because of the
migrants talking about you have to watch
Jesse wat's prime time I 8:00 is it's
bedtime for the baby so I have it on the
background she's a fan mostly when your
mom calls in or texts
um no great replacement Theory to your
point Greg I think you are correct that
there's a decision that he made that he
wanted to go towards kind of a more
nationalized narrative about what's
wrong with the Republican Party versus
being a local city mayor and I think
that it can be difficult when you run
one of these huge cities right that you
don't feel necessarily that you're just
a local guy but that's what it is right
you you have a little plot of land and
that's what you're in charge of and the
people who put you in office and by the
way chose him over Paul valis who still
a Democrat tried and true Democrat here
but had a much tougher stance about
things like immigration and supporting
the police was an option and when I was
watching the footage of the city council
meeting where they wouldn't allow them
to take the vote on maintaining
Sanctuary City status I was thinking are
people having buyers remorse on this
that they should at least have the
option to have a democrat in office
who's going to listen to their
concerns he did inherit a whole host of
problems from Lori Lightfoot and from
the mayor before her and the mayor
before him but homicides in Chicago are
down 10% from this time last year
they're down here in New York they're
down in Philadelphia DC is an outlier in
terms of liberal cities and we've talked
about what's going on in DC a lot um but
I don't think that when people feel so
overwhelmed by what's going on and the
migrant crisis that they're necessarily
sitting at homes and talking about the
broad Strokes of that they're talking
about the fact that they know that a
little girl down the street was shot in
a drive by shooting but I do I mean
murder is obviously the worst crime but
people are leaving the cities not
because of murder but everything crime
in general l
car jacking I'm just saying one of the
things that we talked about was
Jessie leaving New York Jess I left he
forced himself out um anyway all right
that's it bye bye bye bye hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else